all right Steven mm-hmm Steven where'd
you grow up where you from originally
I grew up over and like alhambra area so
far for me yeah suburb of LA yeah and
tell me about your childhood you grew up
with both your parents
no I as early for says like five years
old or so you know your parents split up
yeah I was with my dad for most of my
childhood and that was really cool and
they don't went over to my mom for a
little bit and then she moved so now BEC
I might just like out here on my own you
know how long you been down here in Skid
Row three years two and a half three
years Navy yeah I try not to I don't
know hang out here as much as I can you
know cuz I know it's crazy dangerous and
I'd like to have the life or it's like
progressing you know but I know it's
drugs it's like you can't move very far
out how was your childhood fortunately
it was good I mean the divorce I was
young enough where it I didn't know what
relationships were likes I didn't know
it didn't really haven't affected
because like I still saw mom and dad
they weren't together I just didn't see
relationship because I wasn't yeah you
know I was too young to understand what
relationship was so I mean it was good I
mean my father was a good guy you know
he took care of me a lot you know my mom
was a good mother you know you know I
don't have any siblings but it was cool
you know that's fine and then when you
went on your own
what where'd you go you go to college or
well I attempted that and I was never
really into academics you know but that
was at the same point in time where I
started using drugs so that was like the
critical like pivot you know do I try to
do the academics and do that route or I
mean I wasn't gonna say drugs gonna be a
route of life but that's kind of like
what took over and became
life you know yeah and that's what ended
up happening
Gobert what were the first drugs you
played around with well yeah yeah it was
like marijuana and drinking you know and
then vicodins pills very cool like thing
to do at the time you progressed with
those and then sure enough injuries
happen
you don't pills again and then they give
you a little stronger ones and those
things get harder to get and you just
kind of jump over to opiates or heroin
you know prescription runs out yeah
exactly prescription goes Street you
know Street people price is expensive
doctors alone giving anything you know
that's a common way people get addicted
yeah
and where are you staying now I used to
have a ten around here I've been on the
train quite a bit though cuz I want to
get out of the area you know I really do
so I tell myself to get on the train to
go I get on it and then I go in every
like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna be sick you know
so you gotta come back you know yeah
come back to get your hair on yeah what
do you do for money now
it was like it was like it was boosting
I don't do that anymore
so now I just try to find little stores
and like I try to like you know sweep
there are there a parking lot or like do
some windows if something random
different stores I know you know they'll
help out like 20 bucks they're in there
yeah something honest yeah I don't like
I I want to go jail
I don't know have you been in jail yeah
and I'm tired of tired that you too old
for it the time is not worth the money
you get for stealing you know it's just
a stupid yeah so try and find the honest
work I can't really I mean I can find a
job an actual job paying job with the
check and stuff you know but residents
you know it's hard like a French bawd
school it keeps you clean shower and
stuff but sometimes so crowded that you
know missing missing showers there you
know Thursday for those who don't know
there's a place called the refresh spot
yeah down here where people can take
showers and what else can you do over
there just how you do laundry you charge
your phone if you have one sometimes
they give you like referrals or
different other resources around the
area yeah yeah no I mean there's really
resources for everything and anything
right yeah
there is done it's going to flow the
rehab recovery yeah
shoes the only make it don't seem to
give out our tents right time and time
some places do but I know I noticed with
the clothes and stuff like that you have
to hit him on a good day or the place
themselves are gonna take and give to
their residents there you know yeah did
you ever have dreams of doing something
you longed for goals like a specific
like dream like I got career dream or
just like something like goals I mean I
go yeah you want to become a doctor or
lawyer or anything yes I mean every kid
he's like oh I want to be a doctor or
only be a police officer or something
like that I did too you know I did but I
never followed through with it right now
I could say I'm still in that same place
like I know I gotta have these goals and
I know what I want do in a sense but
it's the first steps I don't know how to
do it you know how do I go about getting
to those positions like like I know I
gotta know how to enrolled in school and
you do that you know I know how to show
up and be on time but um like after that
where does that take you know they gotta
know if I want to go to the construction
site say hey you guys hiring
or not right now go to our website do
that and keep showing up and still no
then I don't know what to do there you
know I don't know how to expand that my
networking skills aren't that that great
yeah yeah didn't your drug is heroin
yeah sometimes crystal meth yeah yeah
yeah being addicted to heroin or meth
you kind of can't really make it through
a full workday right
no oh how you make it through a full
workday but it's making sure I have
something in morning to start that day
is the issue you know having enough
money in the morning to go to work you
know after that it's fine you know
like say if I start a job it's gonna
take two weeks before I start getting
the my first check you know so what am I
gonna do the first two weeks I have to
really try to make sure I don't get
controlled by the law or I have to make
sure I have enough to continue to go to
work you know so yeah absolutely like
kind of really planned out and out here
things don't never go the way they're
supposed to yeah yeah if somebody was to
walk you over to one of their cut
recovery programs here and just like
drop you off and say just stick with it
and follow through and get your life in
order and get out of this neighborhood
and get a job and get your life together
do you think that would work out yeah I
mean I do I do and I don't like I I want
it I want I wanna be in recovery I wanna
be sober I do but also want to have
freedoms to you know I don't want have
to be bound to six seven groups a day
you know which takes up all day and then
the state can't get a job until like six
months into it you know oh [ __ ] I mean I
know that's not any kind of amount of
time six-punch is nothing looking at it
but in that moment sitting there you're
like damn well I wanted to do that now
and it's just that whole I want it now
thing you know kind of cuts it off
blocks it out of the way
I mean I would do it right now I would I
want to you know I just I guess the
uncertainty of the future - yeah do you
think some of this is just your
self-worth is being what it is it kind
of just like puts you into this
situation and you almost feel like
somewhere subconsciously you deserve it
but this is where you belong or
something like that I used to think that
way I used to and actually held like it
was like that for a majority of my
addiction but it wasn't until recently
like that I want to say within the last
I think it was actually getting down
here they actually made me feel I have
more self-worth because I actually saw
like the like the raw and this of this
you know yeah and actually it's kind of
messed up to save it actually kind of
boosted my self esteem almost you know
but I know I know that's not for
everyone you know I know it doesn't
happen for everyone who just say it's
gonna last you who say it's gonna last
you know yeah
it's uh this is the bottom of the barrel
yeah and I know like some people say
they get down here they get off the bus
and they never leave you know that's
kind of so far words happen to me
Greyhound station is right at the end
you can see it from here
yeah that's where people come from all
over the country you get dropped off and
ya think they're gonna go the financial
district every bigger three blocks of it
this way they can't make it the half
mile yeah yeah there's none the rest
their lives here yeah I hope you don't
know I don't want that man I don't hold
it 27 yeah well Stephen thank you for
talking to me and yeah no problem good
luck and I hope you figure out a way to
climb out of this yeah I do
I need to I need to sit down and like
really like thoroughly you just think it
through or just I don't know find out
how to go about it or you know the
resources are here just use them that's
what I got to do just [ __ ] using
things you know
yeah that's where it comes down to half
measures or whole steps that's it yeah
all right well thank you for talking
awesome brother thank you cool
you